meantime a truly historic weather event  is unfolding in texas  from dallas all the way to austin san  antonio  record cold combined with winter weather  has shut down  everything and the situation is serious  there's no water we've been  i'm going to say blessed so i'm always  like i have to try and find  things that you know to be grateful for  our hotel that we're staying at is one  of the few hotels i think there's like  one other hotel that has power  it's been very tough like we've been  lucky like we've just been  pulling together like us for like  whatever we have we've been sharing the  same thing with the water  we've been just extremely lucky trina  marie there says finding food has been  tough as well  she said a pizza shop nearby was able to  open for a few minutes today but  that's about it she hopes that she and  her friends can get out of texas  tomorrow if not  may not be until saturday at the  earliest